I don't think anybody should care about
the gossip.
It put it on my site.
You know,
you don't have to read it.
The great thing about it is it's,
I like to think of my website.
It's like the Mcdonald's of the
Internet.
A lot of people love to criticize
McDonald's,
but yeah,
it's still really popular and I love the
French fries.
I think gossip is
people's interest in gossip is nothing
new.
It's been around for decades.
It's been around for centuries.
The only thing that's changed is the
media has become aware that a celebrity
news can be profitable,
so gossip or celebrity news is now
mainstream news.
I don't know,
but I know that celebrity news is
mainstream news.
I know that Anderson Cooper has
discussed Lindsay Lohan many times and
he probably hates it,
but you know what?
He will continue to discuss about
celebrity news and he will continue to
talk about Lindsay Lohan.
I would not insult the mainstream news
by saying that it's a form of glorified
gossip.
No,
I still think that mainstream news is
very valuable.
Invaluable.
Okay.
Mainstream news is just doing their job.
If they weren't making money,
they wouldn't be able to provide us with
the news.
So they have to have that celebrity
element there so that they can get
ratings.
But,
you know,
not all the times I,
there are those shows that have nothing
to do with politics,
but there's been a shift definitely over
the last five or 10 years where there is
a lot more celebrity content in
mainstream news.
I think celebrity news is only a
positive thing.
I look at it as,
um,
aspirational.
It's a great escape for people and a lot
of them love to fantasize.
Like,
oh,
wouldn't it be great if I were famous to
a,
wouldn't it be great if I can,
um,
go to that shop and buy that fancy
clothes that Kim Kardashian buys.